[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we have a very special episode today we
are going to be talking about aerospace
engineering and to do so we have Creon
Levitt joining us let's thanks Ellen
nice to be here what's up
thanks for coming on to our show greatly
appreciate it and you have the perfect
background to be teaching us about
aerospace engineering with 32 years at
NASA Ames Research Laboratory research
facility Research Center Research Center
most people don't even know that Ames is
in the bay people are like coming in
like fresh to code at all these tech
companies and then we're like by the way
there's a NASA Center down by Google and
singularity University they're like
what's singularity University what's
NASA Ames right yeah and so you were
there for 32 years do we got all this
great work now you're the director of
research at planet that's correct man
you guys are launching and operating the
constellations of satellites that are
imaging the earth and giving us all this
unique data the world's largest
constellation of satellites actually
we've launched over 300 satellites
you're 300 now well we don't have 300 in
orbit at the present but we've launched
about that many yes and so meaning maybe
a hundred of them or so have already
went offline or so yeah about a hundred
have we entered and launching is
different than successfully making it to
orbit so that's the thing we can talk
about a little bit we'll unpack that
okay cool all right so let's start with
you you and your background so I mean 32
years of work at NASA Ames there's so
much to uncover there yeah yeah so walk
us through well we're not going to be
able to cover at all because there's one
has a number of different careers in the
space of several decades like that but I
came out of school with degrees in
computer science and applied math and
came to NASA Ames actually as a
programmer back in the 80s and work
brought some of the first UNIX machines
which is what Linux kind of used to be
called to NASA and some of the first
internetworking in terms of workstations
and supercomputers talking directly to
each other we have a graphic maybe we
should pull oh yeah we have a picture of
well this is a little before my time but
this is a picture of the internet in
1973 when it was called the ARPANET and
they were only a few dozen nodes on it
and if you look along the left-hand edge
there a lot of them say Ames
that's NASA Ames and Ames was central to
the Pacific backbone of the original
internet and it had the first
trans-pacific link on the internet which
is that line to Hawaii and it had the
first supercomputer on the internet
which is the iliac for right there and
so that was really Silicon Valley that
kind of condensed around that mid
California West Coast backbone right
there Stanford NASA Ames and then you
know HP and Apple and all these
companies came about I had Xerox PARC
anyway so that was before my time I was
just maybe learning the jury first yes
bless all of the humans in 1973 who put
this stuff together yeah that's just
insane incredible and yeah I was just
learning to code back then and like
junior high or something but um came to
Ames worked on computers and networks
and then got seduced by physics which
was really my love and there were so
many physicists working there and all
kinds of things particularly at the
start for me was they were working on
aerodynamics and particularly
computational aerodynamics or
computational fluid dynamics so I did a
lot of work on that I worked with
brewster kales connection machine mr.
kalin Danny Hillis had this
supercomputer that they designed and
NASA bought one of them I got to be
friends with them and did a
computational fluid dynamics on the
connection machine and flow
visualization on the connection machine
that led me into this whole like you
know eight or ten years of career doing
data visualization and that's such a
crucial part of a gathering of being
able to see the data in ways that are
relatable and interesting right and
especially when you've got these giant
computers
cranking on these you know massive
simulations producing like terabytes of
data you you I mean the only thing you
can do is to try and make pictures of it
and nowadays you know everybody's heard
about infographics and visualization but
what I was working on was of a different
sort like we were trying to understand
three dimensional flows and understand
turbulence and understand chemical
reactions and stuff like that so it's a
it's more of us we called scientific
data visualization as opposed to like in
fove is where you're trying to make a
something for a facebook meme you know I
don't know what the protocol is for
moving forward on the images it's the
Mitchell this is funny
yes okay so I eventually ended up doing
some software years later for
multi-dimensional data visualization of
really large data sets in real time and
this happens to be a remote sensing data
set which kind of pre-staged my work at
planet but the idea is there's all these
different spectral bands of information
and you can draw boxes and different
colors in different projections of the
high dimensional space and see them in
other projections including an XY
projection on the surface of the earth
so this is just a general technique that
we did a lot of work at Ames at Ames
classic technique called linked scatter
plots where you have a whole bunch of
different projections of
multi-dimensional data into into
two-dimensional projected planes and
then you highlight some points in one of
those projections and they get
highlighted in all the projections so
you draw a yellow box down here and the
yellow points light up everywhere in all
the different views so yeah that was a
fun project and I still use this this I
want to program all the time husk this
so what is the key importance of taking
three-dimensional data and putting it on
a two-dimensional surface well I mean to
put you have to put it on a
two-dimensional surface to see it on a
display yeah what everyone almost all
the time when we talk about 3d graphics
we're really talking about 3d projected
um to 2d graphics we can drag and move
it so what this is it's like ten
dimensional data that's being projected
in a whole bunch of different way
imagine three dimensional data there's
all sorts of ways to project
down to two dimensions all different
views you can write with ten dimensional
or higher dimensional data you can have
even more views but again to put them on
a screen they have to be two-dimensional
so all the views hide something yes and
so you have to be looking at it from
multiple views at once and this this was
called viewpoints because it was sort of
a pun all it did was draw points and it
viewed points from multiple viewpoints
so anyway this continues to get
reincarnated in new operating systems
and platforms and we did I also got
really into chemical reactions and
nanotechnology co-founded the first
federally funded nanotechnology Research
Center which was the computational
molecular nanotechnology group at NASA
Ames this was in like the 90s early
computational molecular nanotechnology
is simulations of atoms and molecules
for nanotechnology purposes we didn't do
that much real chemistry in the
beginning and this is my colleague Chris
Henze many years ago we had this cool
thing I mean this is sort of a fake
rendering here but we had the stereo
display and this big table where P could
people could all wear the glasses and
see the 3d images and then you could
reach in with this wand and grab atoms
and pull them and it would pull back on
your hand then eventually the bond would
snap and it would come out so we had
this system for sort of doing what we
called virtual mechanosynthesis sort of
prototyping and modeling what a Drexler
type of nano assembler might do and that
was a lot of fun we did a lot of
different virtual reality projects there
they didn't really get a whole lot of
traction because back then virtual
reality was too slow and clunky and
expensive so but it was fun and what
eventually turned out to get traction
were these things that just ran on a
workstation or a laptop you know so
everybody could have it but a lot of the
techniques crossed over and this is
becoming more and more of an applicable
way for people to learn is to immerse
themselves into a 3-dimensional world
where they can put
physically grab things and move them
over that's them that's always been the
the draw it's always been the hope I
kind of I was part of what I like to
call the first VR bubble and so we'll
see how this second one yeah it works
out
hopefully not towards only entertainment
and distractive purposes but let's do
more towards educational purposes
enriching purposes yeah yeah I it'll be
interesting to see how that plays out
you know I'm not a VR a our expert
anymore but I'm interested to see what
happens
I think VR is probably a little narrower
than some people hope it to be but they
are may I think very well become
ubiquitous yes correct
yeah so yeah and I did this got me
really into chemistry and I did a lot of
quantum chemistry simulations for a
while this thing here on the screen is
that at the time a very state-of-the-art
simulation and graphic of the quantum
mechanics of water molecules forming a
ch2 and O and then bonding into h2o
that's what this is that's that doesn't
that look like a ch2 as a oh and this is
the quantum mechanical Wow technically
it's the laplacian of the charge density
but it's a particular aspect of the
quantum mechanical wave function that's
a lot to do with reactivity and
chemistry and I've never actually seen
this before that's so interesting so
there's water there's water yeah
visualized in a particular way according
to quantum mechanical wave function and
then it's separating into interest h2
and oh and reforming so that's that was
just these are these naturally form h2 +
Oh naturally tend to oh yeah yeah in
such copious amounts that it makes
oceans and then right well this is it
coincidentally enough this is kind of
the reaction that takes place in a lot
of rocket engines you know if you have
liquid hydrogen liquid oxygen rocket
engine then you're taking hydrogen h2
and oxygen yes and forming water which
is what the exhaust gas is it's what the
exhaust gases but is it and a huge
amount of energy gets released when you
that's what the oxidation half
the okay okay so so it doesn't for water
forms it forms you know high temperature
high velocities water vapor is that what
when you have liquid hydrogen liquid
oxygen in in a rocket in a combustion
chamber design rocket there combusting
they're basically exploding but we call
it combusting because it's inside of a
rocket but yeah hey yeah rocket is
pretty much like a contained explosion
which inside the combustion chamber and
then the exhaust gases go rushing out
the back yeah they're not combusting
here just quick explain to us like well
this is at the molecular level and this
is just very very idealized like it's in
vacuum one molecule you know and they're
just it's just an animation of the
formation and then the disruption it's
really kind of a technical quantum
mechanical investigation here but it led
us to work on much bigger molecules and
much more elaborate visualizations and
yeah so I always have a love for this
quantum chemistry and quite frankly this
is a good example here's the thing
people think Oh quantum mechanics is so
mysterious and chemistry is such a
mysterious confusion I think that
actually three-dimensional visualization
perhaps virtual reality would indeed
really help people understand chemistry
and molecules definitely that is one of
that's why that's why I'm at this yeah I
mean this is not like it's not like
anybody really needed to know about how
water is created but they had never
really visualized molecular quantum
fields in this level of fidelity in
detail correct that's got me some
followers if you will although this was
in that late 90s so their followers
meant something different but yeah went
to a lot of conferences showed more and
more movies of these reactions worked on
our team at NASA on rocket fuels and
biology and drug interactions and some
weird kind of things that we're off the
path for NASA
and then well let's see skipping
skipping forward a bit then we had
eventually this new director come to
NASA Ames Pete worden you should have
him on your show we'd love to have tea
or Myr Air Force general and sort of an
astrophysics professor and he collected
smart people throughout his career and
made friends with them set up a network
and then when he was appointed to be the
director of NASA Ames he kind of reached
out to all of these smart people and he
said you know now's our chance to make a
difference let's come and disrupt and
revolutionize the way things are done at
NASA let's do some all satellites yeah
let's do a you know advanced IT and
cloud computing let's you know really
try and take more risks with smaller
projects instead of huge projects where
you just spend decades trying to buy
down the risk and he got a lot of his
brain trust to come quit their jobs and
move to Silicon Valley and join him at
NASA Ames now I had already been there
for like 20-something years and I saw
this new development happen and then I
was like okay I'm going to become
friends with these people because they
are obviously pretty cool yeah what a
breath of fresh air what a breath of
fresh air too to take on riskier smaller
projects to explore into new categories
that are that have potential to really
one of them blows up and and that's a
big deal it's like putting a lot of eggs
into different baskets yes exactly it's
kind of like I guess the venture capital
portfolio approach where you invest in a
bunch of high-risk things and I hope
that at least one of them pays off well
one of them that did pay off was his was
Pete's emphasis and enthusiasm for small
SATs yes nano satellites and small
satellites and
you know to kind of fast forward a
little bit because satellites prior to
the whole idea of small SATs were
massive right there were size of cars or
school bus exactly they satellites
tended to be very huge and cost hundreds
of millions of dollars or more and then
small satellites started to happen and
that was in like the 90s well it's
complicated the first the very first
satellites in the 60s were small
satellites because that's all that
people could put into orbit yeah but
once the Rockets got big things got big
fast and people kind of forgot about the
really early satellites that were you
know the size of you know that you could
hold in your hand like a loaf of bread I
love bread or some of them were strange
sorts of shapes like icosahedrons and
octahedrons and people tried all sorts
of things Spears you know and then but
fast-forward to you know the mid 2000
2005 area this renaissance or like
rebirth of nano SATs happen small sets
had in the sense of like SATs that only
weighed a few hundred kilograms
they'd been happening in the 90s and
stuff like this but because of Moore's
law and the you know huge increase in
sophistication and power of micro
electronics that were small and didn't
weigh very much in the 2000s you could
start to build satellites with a lot of
sophistication that were small at least
in theory nobody was really doing that
various universities and stuff were
building and launching these little cube
sets but they were pretty crude so a
bunch of people who I worked with at
NASA who were many of them were P
wardens protegees
and others joined in we're working on a
Nanosat product project at NASA Ames
called phonesat and then a bunch of them
decided hey we could really do something
here we could make a nano sat like the
size of a loaf of bread that would
actually in large numbers provide a very
useful surface imaging the whole earth
at moderate resolution
every day and will marshal the CEO of
planet and Robbie Singler his co-founder
and a bunch of other people most of whom
are still at Planet started the company
in the garage at rainbow mansion we all
fixed a picture of the garage I think
yeah at some point anyway and oh yeah
there it is there's there's the garage
and Cupertino you know the same old
story and there's on the front on the
table on the front edge of that table is
our first one of the first satellites
called the Dove satellites tended to
always be named after birds of prey so
the founders the planet wanted to name
it after a bird of mm-hmm
peace today whistle that's a good one
round so yeah so uh that satellites were
named after birds of prey well lots of
aerospace things airplanes satellites
you know yeah a lot of times they were
so it's nice to have a peaceful yeah the
world the whole the whole idea was to
build these things to help the world yes
okay all right many people had built
satellites to try and help the world
there'd been lots of Earth imaging
satellites built before these like
Landsat and also maybe RapidEye which
we'll talk about but these were the
first earth imaging nano sets and these
were different than than this sort of
university style cube sets that had been
made these had high-speed radios like
miraculous radios and as in the
communication was very fast yes so you
because you need that down from space at
least you need very fast communications
if you're going to be taking
high-resolution images yes you have to
get those images down to earth so these
had you know high-quality telescopes in
them high megapixel count digital image
sensors in them all the other little
things you need in a satellite like
computers and memory and
attitude control system so you can tell
which direction you're pointed and then
point yourself in a particular direction
yes yes
you know Star cameras are rising cameras
Sun sensors reaction wheels which allow
the satellite to point in different
directions yeah as well as radios to
receive commands coming up and
high-speed radios to send the images
back down to earth and so one of the
early planet radio engineers developed
this really sort of brilliant high speed
radio design that was you know the size
of a book of matches instead of the size
of a shoebox like the other radios that
people were selling big deal and in the
very first one of those radios that we
launched in one of these early Dov
satellites you know it came over at the
ground station and it sent information
down to the ground station and then that
one 10-minute pass over that ground
station it downloaded more information
than all of the Nano sets that had ever
been launched had downloaded in their
entirety so wow that radio took us that
radio and the images these things the
very first images that came from these
satellites were actually good you could
see trees you could see houses you could
see damn rivers and and forestry and you
know you could really tell to some
extent what was going on color and you
know it worked and so the idea was to
build a distributed constellation of
about a hundred of these and so that
took a long time - well not a long time
in space years but it took you know like
like five years went by and now we have
over a hundred of these things in orbit
close to 200 and you know they are way
higher quality than these early ones
they carry capture much wider field of
view they're sharper they're taking in
many spectral bands and they're
bringing down about it I think each one
brings down about a terabyte a day whoa
okay might be slightly wrong about that
but that's roughly within the word let's
start unpacking some of the things that
you can teaching so okay as technology
has become better over time the
technology inside the small SATs has
become better so we've been upgrading
the technology a lot of the technologies
become better some of the technology was
kind of already mature like telescopes
people have been building telescopes for
like 200 years okay or 400 years
you go back to Galileo right and and but
but a lot of the telescope technology is
fairly mature and some of the satellite
technology was also fairly mature we
just miniaturized it and I mean
literally just made it a small
miniaturized the radio transmission so
let's say let's unpack some more so hey
okay so there so what as the small set
is orbiting Earth and will show some
orbital mechanics stuff that as it's
orbiting it can only you said there's
about a 10-minute window as it's going
over a station a ground station ground
stations are those big those things that
have dishes they look like big satellite
dishes because they are satellite dishes
and they they can steer so they can
track the satellite as its going
overhead yes all these satellites our
satellites are in lower Earth orbit so
they don't just sit there at one spot in
the sky like most communication
satellites do it low Earth orbit is
about 200 miles yeah roughly speaking to
300 miles yes and then and then you're
moving a a so you're moving Sally radio
satellite on earth that's the ground
station the ground station is additional
tracks the move this is tracking the
motion and receiving the signal as it's
going overhead right but it takes about
ten minutes for the satellite to go from
Horizon to Horizon you get a full
minutes of data collection and you can
like you said you can get a whole
terabyte in a day well as its passing
and it's gonna yeah the the geometry of
the satellites and the ground stations
and the rotation of the earth is
complicated yes but if you have enough
ground stations then
each satellite can usually talk at least
once per orbit and the orbit is about 90
minutes so to make several contacts per
day yes so you can get down a lot of
data from a satellite
and the more ground stations you have to
some extent the more data you can get
down and the better your radio sorry the
more data you can get down the lower
your altitude to some extent the more
data you can get down there's all these
different trade-offs and this whole
thing is orchestrated you know I mean in
the past you'd have hundreds of people
operating one satellite and everything
would be planned in great detail we have
the opposite situation we have like one
person operating 100 satellites so
everything is automated and everything
is run in the cloud and the sequencing
is kind of more like it's kind of like
air air route management like you got
all these satellites going overhead and
all these ground stations in different
places and different priority of
information on different satellites yes
so you have to have a fairly
sophisticated scheduling system kind of
like an airline scheduling system where
you've got gates and airports and
flights and you have to you know you
have to try and optimize a lot of
different things at once and be ready
for problems because inevitably
something's gonna fail or not work you
know you lose that like come over you
don't make contact with it now what do
you do you have to reschedule everything
make contact with it yeah I was
envisioning the the small SAP moving and
communicating with one ground station
and then it gives a certain amount of
its data and then it has out there and
it's orbiting a different part of the
earth and it communicates of the
different ground station for the rest
that's exactly when you guys at home are
compiling that and making sure that it's
giving all of its data then you have to
clean the sat of its data and enable it
to have more oh and it's more
complicated than that even it might
start to fill up before you've gotten
everything down and then it's like then
what do you do and then you're all of a
sudden like maybe something's wrong with
one of the solar panels and the
batteries are getting low
and you have to re re prioritize
charging the batteries so when you're
charging the batteries you can't
necessarily no be taking pictures of the
earth or sending data down there's all
these different things that the
satellite has to do to maintain its
health and so that stuff all has to be
scheduled and you have to have margins
like you never want to actually brown
out right so you want to be keeping
track of your battery charge that you
don't get to a state where you're you
know needing some emergency kind of
protocols where it's basically useless I
mean every one of these satellites up
there even though they're small and even
though they're inexpensive they're a
sizable investment right so you want to
guess you cope so a couple quick
questions how BIG's the team now I think
the team at Planet is between three and
four hundred people if you count outs
you should count Berlin you count San
Francisco and you count Mountain View
yes some of that has come about through
acquisition yeah we acquired a company
called rapid eye I think we have a
picture let's show that I than are like
on a set of larger satellites and that
something else but I got space degree
two we know I forgot all about this
maybe maybe let's do let's do a quick
visit to space debris Ron go back one
and then we'll and then we'll get to the
team and and more so with orbital
mechanics I mean this was kind of what
we were describing before is that the
satellite is going overhead and then
this is the this would be just like a
facility of a ground station where
you're connecting I know that's not this
is the laser facility but am i saying
that that this is how you would get the
information and then it would go
continue collecting information etc but
this is when you're actually trying to
help make sure that the orbital
mechanics of the satellite are staying
in proper trajectory well so so much the
satellite that this this little sphere
that a debris is the idea if that is
that is a piece of space junk
that has no propulsion and has no active
capacity to do anything it's just
following Newton's laws basically
and let's and we're tracking all this
stuff
well planet isn't we're protecting our
stuff but the governments of the world
particularly the US government has
what's called a space situational
awareness Network and many dozens of
different kinds of radars and telescopes
all over the world that are trying to
keep track of as much of the objects in
orbit around the earth as they can so
basically they track everything that's
say 10 centimeters in size or larger and
some stuff that's smaller
now we're getting better graders that
contract stuff that's smaller so they're
tracking tens of thousands of objects
that are in orbit and if we go to the
next slide quick you can see all of the
crazy pieces of Wow except this is a
difference this is a simulation again on
a big multi panel display that we
developed at NASA Ames called the hyper
wall and this happens to be will
Marshall although he's in the shadow
there but that is an actual isn't it not
or is that the simulation Oh like the
actual that may be a visualization of
the actual number of tracked objects the
bottom ones with the huge cloud our
simulated catalog of everything down to
one centimeter in size that's orbiting
the Earth that is how did we how did we
do that already
it just seems how did we get that much
junk up there have just been launching
for like 50 60 years how did we manage
them well that's not a long story one is
that you know earlier on nobody cared
about space debris nobody thought it
would ever be a problem because space
was so big if you will and so early on
there weren't really any rules or
guidelines you'd launch stuff and they'd
like have all these explosive bolts and
different things to make this rocket
stay just separate and to deploy the
satellite like they deploy the satellite
off of the rocket and like pieces would
go flying because who cares you know it
was like a typical you know pollution
kind of situation at the beginning when
people don't think about long-term
long-term consequences yes how do you
let's pay colliding with space junk when
we go to the space station and stuff
like that how do you avoid you know
cutting ahead by riding with faith John
yeah well there's a lot of different
systems the first system is this
tracking system so you try and keep
track of where it is or at least where
the really dangerous pieces are which
are the bigger pieces and you if you're
keeping track of where they are you just
have to be very careful to not launch in
any sort of a trajectory that's going to
intersect one of them and to do in the
case of the space station they do debris
avoidance maneuvers they'll get warnings
like a few days in advance that there
may be a close approach with a piece of
debris and since the debris can't move
yeah the space station will actually it
has little been motors on it for you
know little rocket thrusters on if you
don't go very slowly move a little bit
yeah but if it does this it'll get away
now if it if they're still afraid like
sometimes it moves out of the way but
the predictions weren't so good because
the tracking wasn't so good and maybe
they actually moved even closer into the
path of the oncoming object so then they
will actually they have some shields on
the windows and stuff like that that
they'll close and then they'll go like
actually get into the capsules and get
ready to abandon ship until the close
approach has passed and this has
happened a number of times and it's um I
couldn't imagine losing the space
station well and if that's the other
problem is that if something collides
with the space station or if anything
collides with anything it makes a big
cloud of more debris more debris and you
know bad has actually happened a few
times so things are colliding and making
even more dimension so there's this
whole possibility of a runaway chain
reaction that could actually make space
pretty much unusable by humans at least
for you know decades eventually most of
the stuff in low Earth orbit comes down
because there's some atmospheric drag
and there's solar radiation and
different things that that serve to
eventually bring it down but in higher
orbits like a thousand kilometers or two
thousand kilometers
can stay up for centuries no of course
there's more space as you go further
away but this is horrible this is this
is this thing which is sometimes called
the Kessler syndrome this runaway chain
reaction of space debris which may or
may not be happening I mean that's a
whole story completely run away already
versus if it's where it is now yeah it's
probably at a place where you know
obviously if we stopped all cola I mean
if we stopped all collisions between
large objects it would get better
because there's a natural cleaning that
takes place that's a very important
thing to do is to figure out how to do
that
so that's what so okay so people have
come up with all kinds of schemes for
getting rid of space debris oh they want
to send up satellites with nets to catch
stuff there's harpoons or giant balls of
sticky glue or magnets you know or and
all these things are a very expensive
and it's unlikely that anyone is gonna
spend fifty a hundred million dollars
you know to go catch one or two pieces
of space junk
yeah and be every time you try to catch
a piece of space junk you actually if
you screw up you can become a piece of
space junk doesn't make worse yeah so we
just have to have a better long-term
foresight into what is going on here and
figure out how to clean things up a
little bit to make it even easier we
have so we came up with it or we came up
with a plan which was slightly different
our plan was that you monitor everything
which were content which is already
happening I mean not everything but
everything is that's large enough to see
by radar or telescope and then when you
see that there's going to be a collision
particularly a collision between two
pieces of debris which there's where you
really can't you can't tell one to get
out of the way I mean you know nobody's
got operating thrusters or anything like
that it might just be like a piece of
the bolt or somebody
is that where the laser comes in that's
where this laser you go back one Ron
quick so that's where this laser idea
yeah the idea of the laser so the idea
is you track the you predict a collision
or close approach you can usually never
really predict a collision you predict a
close encounter if you will between two
pieces of debris you track them get
their trajectories lock down have some
lasers on telescopes point these lasers
at the debris and just shine the light
on the debris and you might say well
what's that going to do but it turns out
that the radiation pressure over the
course of several hours of this you
could do over the course of say two or
three days with maybe one to ten of
these laser ground stations that
radiation pressure photon pressure light
pressure or light force which is what we
called the project we called it project
light force that would be enough to
nudge the debris out of the way so it
doesn't encounter this collision
let's have possibly moves it into
collision course with another well you
try and keep track of all this stuff by
tracking everybody and you don't move
stuff out of the frying pan it's the
fire ideally yes correct and it doesn't
have to work all the time it just has to
work statistically enough of the time to
slow the collision rate to slow the
growth rate to the point where we don't
have a runaway situation and let's maybe
go back to planet NOW well let me just
say what this is actually being done now
this we had a partnership with the
Australian organization that does laser
arranging and stuff like that at Mount
Stromlo Observatory in Australia and
they're actually setting up a system to
test this out not just laser tracking
but actually laser nudging and you might
think this requires some kind of giant
weapons-grade you know death ray but no
this requires a laser about the size of
a laser that's used in a big laser
cutter in an industrial manufacturing
facility and it requires a telescope
that's like a one meter or
one-and-a-half meter class telescope and
there are hundreds and hundreds of those
all over the world yeah
and so this whole system could set up
and run autonomously for a few hundred
million dollars with enough of these
laser stations we could get in full
control of space debris and me no I
wouldn't maybe go that far but we could
do a lot like a divorce could push it
enough to get out of war but as well I
don't think you could do that okay now
and what it it's not a weapon like it's
not going to blast vaporize anything
it's just not yet just nut is it with
about the same pressure that the light
from the Sun not just stuff which does
it does do and that's actually a
significant force that you have to take
into account when you're calculating
satellite orbits the radio solar
radiation pressure so anyway this is
being continued to be worked on
sometimes I get frustrated and I think
that the reason the u.s. isn't doing it
discuss it's not expensive enough like
yes you know like they're like what a
few hundred million dollars you know
what's in it for me so it's like you you
but the Australians bless them are
continuing to work on this and meanwhile
we do what we can a planet with you know
200 satellites let's show some of those
okay yeah yeah let's move on to maybe
two slides forward on try to be good
citizens and get ourselves out of the
way when we are okay alright so here's
here's this I think 42 or 38 or
something that Dov satellites okay this
is the Dove satellite they all have
these little silver carrying handles
attached to them so that they can be
stacked on top of each other and
everything and not mess each other up
these are these are these were in the
Netherlands or something like that being
integrated into a a launch deployer
system that then got shipped to Russia
to be integrated onto a Soyuz rocket
these satellites are now in orbit so and
as we look at them we see that this here
is our solar cells that are gonna fold
out and you show those in a bit and then
we have the the telescope sits on offer
on this rocket it would sit on this side
of the rock and you on the satellite on
the satellite sorry on this side of the
satellite it would open up and then the
telescope would be able to cap right
there kind of like a lens cap over the
telescope when it's in the stowed
configuration and yes lens cap pops open
and becomes a radio antenna and the
solar arrays pop out like wings yes and
and we'll show that as well and then
this is where the camera and other
optical measuring gear radio yeah yeah
there's electronics and radio don't
crammed in all over the place every
cubic centimeter is filled up because
these things are very dense they're much
more dense they're dense like a laptop
computer yes or than they are like a
typical saddle and then what does that
weigh I think about four and a half
kilos that's really light actually but
yeah okay cool let's go on to the next
one Ron so oh here's this rapid eye
these are that this is the rapid eye
constellation which we also operate that
was launched about 10 years ago about to
have the 10th anniversary of rapid eye
they're still up in space going strong
and Planet acquired that constellation
and the group of people in Berlin and
Canada who were managing it and
processing the data as as part of a
merger with black bridge rapid eye and
so these engines these satellites are
interesting they're about the size of
maybe a large mini-fridge yeah one you
have in the car and so they weigh maybe
a hundred and twenty 130 kilos and for
their time they were considered small
SATs and technically they still are
small SATs is like 150 kilos and they
were the first Earth imaging satellites
produced on a production line like they
were made five of them in parallel and
they launched all five of them on one
rocket and they were sort of the
Pathfinders and pioneers in this idea of
an earth imaging constellation
rather than a few rather than like one
or two special-purpose super expensive
satellites that's alright
business launched in 2000 2007 or 2008
doesn't hate anything cool built maybe
over the year or two before that but
yeah this company was kind of the
company that built them Surrey
satellites and space technology were
kind of the inspirational mentor company
yeah planner planet cool so this is this
is our first step into the small sack
constellations for Earth imaging for
Earth imaging right cool this is rapid
eye and we were talking about dove
earlier Ron let's go on to the next one
oh I don't know is there next one yeah
there is we slept through the full dove
images oh here's some yourselves being
deployed from the sword from deployed
from the space station which we don't
actually do anymore we enter a station
was a great kind of subsidized ride for
us because you go on the commercial
resupply missions exactly but then they
have extra space they sell off that
space pretty cheap and also quite
frankly the government that's our 15
minutes I'm thankful and quite frankly
the US government and other governments
are trying to encourage us say politely
they're encouraging commercial use of
the space station so we were one of the
big commercial users and they encouraged
it by giving relatively cheap rides for
year up there and our satellites went up
there and they would deploy them and
it's not really the orbit that we prefer
but it's an inexpensive ride and we did
a lot of testing from the space station
because we can go up pretty frequently
and we try out new technology and we got
to go through a lot of iterations that's
great or is that like designed by
deploying the space station but now we
tend to just take rides that go to the
orbits we want in yet this is this is
maybe a key point to address now why is
this is what 250 miles up or so why is
this not the ideal orbit and what is the
ideal orbit and now how do you launch up
well that's a bit of a technical matter
but here's the thing if you're taking
pictures of the earth every day you
would like for the lighting condition
to be the same every day to the extent
possible now obviously you have weather
and certain things that that make the
lighting quite variable but let's say on
a clear day you'd rather probably not
have the light coming from all different
angles depending on what day it is and
the Space Station orbit that's what
happens when you go over you know
Chicago or whatever it might be it's
always at a different time of day
with the orbits that we choose to go
into and most Earth observing satellites
choose to go into they're called Sun
synchronous orbits and they're it's a
sign of a technical thing going over
Chicago at 2 p.m. every day exactly
right interesting that way you can image
it that way when you see changes from
one day to the next they're not just
changes in lighting lighting angle
exactly they're changes in something
that actually happened it's not just
shadows moving around because that's not
really all that interesting I mean you
can use moving you can use the shadows
to learn things about three-dimensional
structure but Oh totally
but if you're trying to do things like
we are like monitor crops and monitor
the movement of ships and this sorts of
thing then you would like consistent
lighting and there's one set of orbits
that have that teach us about that quick
as quick as we can if possible ok the
here's the situation the earth is not a
perfect sphere the earth is more like a
football right or a pancake sort of
thing it's it's it's like that guy
you've got on the table right there yes
right that that egg-shaped thing it's
wider at the equator because it's
spinning and it bulges out at the
equator well if you have a satellite in
orbit around a non spherical object and
the orbit is that angle the orbit will
tend to process the the orbital plane
does not stay constant around a sphere
the orbital plane would stay constant
with respect to the fixed stars a
perfect sphere it's a perfect sphere but
since the earth is not the orbit as'
what's called precesses the orbital
plane precesses yeah now that would seem
like it's even worse like the orbit
keeps changing processing but you got to
understand it if it didn't precess it
would stay fixed with respect to the
fixed
which would mean as the earth goes
around the Sun the time of day is always
going to be changing when you're going
over Chicago as we were saying but if
the orbit is precessing and you can get
the orbit to precess exactly once per
year now oh the orbit processes with
respect to the fixed stars once per year
but that's exactly what the earth is
doing going around the Sun once per year
and so that's called a Sun synchronous
orbit so it keeps the Sun relatively in
the same location all the time and
anyway so then once per day you're
orbiting the same location or is it
multiple times per day you're able to
sorry photograph the same location at
the same time no it's really that the
angle between the Sun the earth and the
end the satellite is relatively constant
that's what you want to clip that
enables you to photograph Chicago at
2:00 p.m.
once per day or multiple times per day
or well that's also complicated because
that depends whether you could multiple
times well you could multiple times per
day if you're willing to do not look
straight down all the time if you're
willing to look to the side you might
pass at Chicago more than once per day
if you I mean you've got to look to the
side to pass it once per day it it takes
a hundred of our satellites roughly
speaking looking straight down to pass
everywhere once per day ok that's it
they're looking to question I got asked
though it could I could it would it take
a lot of energy to keep the satellite in
perfect orbit around just Chicago if you
just want a photograph Chicago that you
can't actually do that it's impossible
to do that well impossible is the strong
yeah it's it's it's a it's completely
impractical try that go now you can have
a satellite in geostationary orbit and
there it's at the equator orbiting once
per day so the earth it's over the same
spot of the earth at all times
approximately and that is what
communication satellites do yes even
that because the earth is not a perfect
sphere and the moon and things it never
works out exactly like these things
referenced in the video that we have as
well no the video that we have
kind of a one or two minute summary
video of Planet story well let's um
let's do that let's do this next image
let's do that and I will unpack all of
this in more detail hopefully out of the
future aerospace engineering episode
because this there's so much ignorance
that I have in that I'd like to
understand more about it fairly
complicated a bit of business orbital
mechanics I mean people spend their life
studying orbital mechanics we have quite
a few specialists at Planet and orbital
mechanics and and yeah there's a lot
going on there but the the basics are
easily visualizable and understood yes
which probably helped with virtual
reality though you know exactly yeah
yeah correct so jump dump us right in
this is so interesting so that they'd
come they'd go up initially they'd go up
and you would they'd land within the
commercial resupply then the astronauts
that are in the ISS would take the small
SATs and push them out of the airlock
the yeah pretty kind of as a few more
steps to us than that but yes yeah
absolutely thank you that used to be the
the path and then they would unfold and
folks our imaging and then talk to the
ground stations but now you guys go up
and then you're deployed at a different
stage rather than all the way up to the
ISS you know we actually go higher than
the ayah you go higher than the ISS is
very low 250 miles right and you now go
300 or so miles well no actually I think
I don't think in miles I think in
kilometers and and the is our normal
orbit is about 500 kilometers and the
ISS is significantly lower than 500 or
400 right a 440 or 420 I think moves
around depending on these debris events
and but more so depending on they don't
want it to get too low because then
there's too much drag and then it gets
even lower but they don't want to
necessarily have it be too high because
they're spending a lot of time looking
at the earth and it's actually nice to
look at the earth when you're a little
closer yeah I mean that's one advantage
to our ISS deployments is that they say
they're closer so these things that
higher resolution res yeah yeah that's
an interesting point so okay so now
you're flying further past it and being
deployed further right and we're being
deployed by by rockets without any
people and
there's no no one to watch it sometimes
there's like selfie cams on the Rockets
that they do the things deploying in
fact that's in the video there's a big
okay lets our legs employ our big 88 set
deploy I think is captured partially on
that video yes so now you're usually
going up with other satellites and other
resources had a few dedicated launches
smaller smaller boxes that's huge yeah
Ron let's go to the next slide it's just
a video I think if we wouldn't know wait
what about the small set what about dove
the the white oh that's right here yeah
yeah yeah perfect well I want to close
like I want to at least give a detail
all right everybody tune in in very
close detail right now okay so I'm gonna
I'm gonna start and you're gonna
interrupt me if I'm doing things
incorrectly so okay so this is the these
are the foldable so these fold back in
because it's deployed as just one
rectangle right and then this is covered
this lens cap is covered as it's
deploying so then as as it pushes out as
it gets put into orbit then this the
lens cap comes off the the wings jut out
so the solar cells have room to breathe
there's more solar cells here on top
then yeah the solar cells are on the
other side on the light panel correct
those light panels are just a decorative
and they're beautifully they have
animals and radio waves and all kinds of
exactly there's no horse Sterns our art
director who got us all into putting
drawings on the satellites first his
drawings but then eventually everybody's
drawings and their kids drawings and
contests for drawings and that's awesome
every satellite they draw every
satellite that goes up is covered with
art that's great and because you can't
actually put solar cells on both sides
of the panel's well the Sun doesn't
shine on both sides of the panel's in
general but it would but you could there
then then you won't have to move the
well son right I suppose but you also
really need to radiate heat and white is
good for radiating heat in fact one of
the constraints on the drawings is that
they don't have too much much black yeah
yeah that's interesting okay so now so
this is this is a telescope side on the
telescope side you have a three and a
half inch mirror and that's that's
continuously taking the light that's
reflected from the earth and capturing
that light
then you have a camera here in the
system on the back the camera system
captures that and then and then the then
it holds the data until you go over the
ground station and then the radio
transmitter sends the information to the
ground station there's so many other
important pieces on the stats you've got
the basics you've got the basics right
and sure yeah and there's a bunch of
other components and a bunch of
operational modes but that's the basic
idea take pictures when you're over land
mostly and sometimes when you're over
water charge your batteries when you're
over water in the Sun at night when you
can't charge your batteries or take
pictures send data down to the ground
stations when you pass over them by
night day night day that happens every
45 minutes you you go from night to day
or day tonight because it takes about 90
minutes to do it
oh yeah that's so cool so if you're
flying over water
you're recharging as if the Sun's up
yeah and then if you're if it's
nighttime you're trying to fly over
ground stations so you can down link the
downlink that's so interesting I love
all of this nuance and I love seeing
this and I'm so happy and Ron if you can
do a quick capture with one of the Robo
cams up at the satellite imagery that we
have that's ours its I'm not sure if I
want to advertise that in the tree
basically what we're trying to get at at
least say is that this is you know you
guys have taken a lot of really
important of photos of Earth a lot of
companies have taken important photos of
Earth and you have everything from Bora
Bora to the Chilean coastline or
Argentina and coastline wanted to to you
know South Korean refineries and Chinese
dams through the Golden Gate Bridge Palo
Alto Redwood City and those shipping
yards for where we transit all our goods
just all these different amazing things
you can teach us a quick one this is
this is really important you're
observing climate you're observing crop
yields you're observing urban area
planning disaster response yeah yeah
yeah those things climate climate not so
much I mean we look at ecological things
like deforestation
and agriculture and coral reefs but
climate we're not really we don't really
do climate climate is a specialized type
of satellite that needs very super
precision temperature readings and
radiation radiometers and and bolo
meters and things like this so we that's
more of a NASA thing but defore station
and coral reefs are definitely still in
the ballpark ish oh yeah we definitely I
mean we look we just image the earth we
aim it's the coasts we image the land we
emit some things out in the ocean the
uses of that data are just manifold and
more and more all the time
now a big influence a big emphasis at
our company is on analytics which means
nobody can actually look at terabytes of
images that doesn't make any sense what
they want is actionable information how
many houses were built in this province
in the last month Wow how many trees
were planted you know in this region are
there any new roads in this region are
there any ships moving around that don't
correspond with ships on the ship
tracking radio system yeah it's a big
issue because ships try and spoof
where they are so they can go fish where
they're not supposed to with things like
that that is not so we're got customers
who have all these different modes of
utilizing the data and it keeps
bootstrapping up to higher and higher
levels where now we're making automatic
time series so people don't have to look
at images at all or we find when
something has changed and then we task
one of our high-resolution satellites to
go look and see what's actually changed
and then if it's a change that triggers
a certain alert maybe a human will go
look at it yeah it's all kind of moving
up to ever higher levels it's so cool
that you can start using a image
processing machine learning for image
processing so you can see if things have
changed drastically to the point where
you need a human to to come and look at
it and be like whoa look at that crazy
change or how many people are moving
into a new area how many new houses are
being built or well people we we can't
really see people on what's green can't
see what all our satellites even our
high-resolution axis you see houses but
as we know so that's high energy some
like that
there's tons of houses or even in the
u.s. they put houses with no people
because you know they miss calculate
their real estate development project
project anyway but how many people s
fishing one was crazy as well that one
was nuts
these are all such interesting use cases
for small SATs for image and if anybody
has a use case or a project that they
want to do they should contact they
should go to planets website we have a
free data program links in the bio for
Netcom right we have plant that we you
can sign up for certain amounts of free
data we have open California where you
can get I think I think you can get all
of California including historical and
if you're an academic or a non-profit or
a non-government organization or even a
citizen scientist you can utilize our
data without having to pay anything or
without having to pay much depending on
how much you want bless planet for open
sourcing so much of their data on its we
yeah we have it so we have to pay the
bills and you do have to pay the bills
and so if you want huge amounts of data
that's up to the minute you're gonna pay
for it but if you want small amounts of
data for a science project yeah we'll
try to come be that is so awesome
seriously bless you guys for for doing
that and and we hope to be able to
support you in every single way because
imaging the earth is so important for
everything that you just listed I think
I saw on the Wikipedia page there was a
you were capturing a volcano slowly
emitting smoke so startingly captured
all those lava flows in Hawaii mark
after that arch dawn yeah it's I mean
that's crazy and you could warn people
and be like get the hell out of that
area lavas coming your way
he had disaster preparedness Disaster
Response it's important one of the
important things with disaster responses
when a disaster happens all kinds of
satellites start looking at it but they
weren't looking at it the day before or
the week before our satellites were yes
and so we can tell you what got covered
up and what was there and we've had a
lot of that's great as that yeah we had
this sort of time machine where we can
go back in time at any place anywhere on
the earth go back in time and see where
what was and it doesn't matter how many
satellites you have
doesn't many how big your satellites are
if you aren't imaging the whole earth
every day you can't go back in time
you're like the Wayback Machine before
yeah right yeah I love that that's so
important to be able to have okay this
has been such such a pleasure I'm so
happy to have learned about more about
aerospace engineering orbital mechanics
satellites small SATs all the nuance of
the engineering of those and how they
work in working with the earth it's
amazing just a very couple quickies that
we like to ask our guests on the way out
do you think we're alone in the cosmos I
think we should behave it I think we
should cherish our consciousness and our
planet and our future as if we were
alone in the cosmos I kind of hope we
are alone in the cosmos because if we
aren't alone in the cosmos the scenarios
don't look so great I'm aware of the
great filter controversy the doomsday
scenarios but yeah I have a seat no one
knows if we're alone or not or they know
one should say they know but I believe
that until there's clear evidence to the
contrary we should comport ourselves as
if we're alone because we may be the
universe's one experiment experiment
with intelligent life so let's make sure
we get it right
god bless the consciousness being having
evolved on this planet yeah thank you
for making that a very clear point do
you think that we're in a simulation oh
that's a that's a we're in the
simulation TV show so I guess we are um
no I do not and that but that's a long
discussion right there's a lot of
technical reasons why I think we're not
there you think well I think yeah I
think it's highly unlikely and again I
think we should comport ourselves as if
we are not I think nothing would be
stupider than to pretend than to act as
if we're in a simulation because what if
we're wrong it's like I mean this is a
general sort of Neil list at
right it's like oh it doesn't matter if
we blow ourselves up there's thousands
of planets with life throughout the
galaxy and intelligence is common so who
cares what happens to humans yeah but
that's very aunt lemon that's one of the
are that's a very strong man argument on
like the book could what is the steel
man version of the argument of well the
reason I brought that up was not to not
to knock the seti or something like that
but to say that the simulation argument
seems an even worse oh we did
interesting I wonder if that's due to
the battery or what it's okay what is
that on one of the two yeah well yeah
that it's okay well yeah yeah we'll
quote will close the show can you hear
me on this mic right okay cool
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world what do I think
you're gonna have to give these
questions out in advance the most
beautiful thing in the world to meet
personally or just overall I think the
most beautiful the most I think one of
the most beautiful things in the world
are some of the things that you see with
psychedelics
but obviously the creations of humans
like the great cathedrals and the great
works of art are beautiful and of course
nature is also beautiful so I have no
idea to answer that question I tend to
not be an absolutist that has one
favorite anything like I couldn't even
tell you what my favorite food is much
less what's the most beautiful thing in
the world so you know but let's keep
trying to find out
psychedelics do unveil some interesting
aspects of reality
thank you very much crayon thank you so
much for coming on to our show we
greatly appreciate it thank you for
having me it was a pleasure and now
you've got a new pet Rance of supporter
and a new audience member and me we
greatly appreciate that so much
and you heard it you heard it here first
all this amazing stuff about aerospace
engineering definitely go and tune in
more tune in more into aerospace
engineering and space in the cosmic
perspective the overview effect why does
all of this matter go and create what
this content don't just consume go write
about it go make videos about it and go
and inspire other people to care about
it start businesses about it
subscribe comment below join the family
during the conversation join us on
patreon you heard it here from Creon as
well join us support us help us grow
this helped us impact more people with
this much love everyone thank you so
much for tuning in thanks Ron for
producing directing alright much love
see you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]